Перед другим туром президентських виборів
у столичних відділах Державного реєстру виборців - натовпи людей.
Всіх цих людей сюди привела віра в те, що їхній голос має значення.
А також - проблеми з голосуванням.
Хтось не знайшов себе у списках виборців,
інші - хочуть змінити дільницю, бо не можуть проголосувати за місцем реєстрації.
Для Неллі Селютіної це єдина можливість скористатися правом голосу.
Адже прописана вона в окупованому Донецьку.
Каже, що перед першим туром все зробила швидко.
Люди були, але лише кілька - 5 чи 6.
У нас все зайняло 15-20 хвилин.
Звісно, з такою чергою, як зараз, не порівняти.
Виходить, є лише вісім днів на те, щоб змінити виборчу адресу.
Треба дуже хотіти скористатися своїм виборчим правом, щоб витримати усе це.
Щоб проголосувати не за місцем реєстрації, необхідно підтвердити таку потребу.
Наприклад, надати довідку з місця роботи чи навчання в іншому місті,
договір оренди житла або квитки на поїзд чи літак на дату голосування.
І тільки для людей з реєстрацією на окупованих територіях
процедуру максимально спростили.
Їм достатньо пред’явити лише паспорт.
Попри це, навіть перед першим туром виборів
подати заяву встигли не всі охочі – адже у черзі всі рівні.
У мене є знайомі, котрі не змогли скористатися своїм виборчим правом.
В основному, це люди,  які прийшли в останні дні.
Тоді тут теж були такі ж великі черги.
Коли людина працює і потрібно відпрошуватися, це досить складно.
Найскладніше проголосувати тим, у кого реєстрації немає взагалі.
Адже змінювати їм нічого: немає штампу у паспорті –
немає виборчої адреси.
Таких громадян в Україні, за оцінками експертів,
щонайменше 700.000. Тобто – майже 4 відсотки
від кількості виборців, що прийшли на дільниці у першому турі.
І більше, ніж відрив Петра Порошенка від Юлії Тимошенко.
27-річний айтішник Дмитро Федоров – один із них.
У 2014 році, після закінчення університету,
його виписали зі столичного гуртожитку.
Зареєструватися за старою адресою Дмитро не міг –
адже його рідний Сімферополь тоді вже контролювали росіяни.
Тож за виборчу адресу і право обирати владу
Дмитрові довелося боротись.
У громадській організації «Група впливу», яка допомагає виборцям-переселенцям,
його тепер зустрічають як героя. Адже шанси на успіх були мізерні.
На початку лютого я прийшов у Державний реєстр виборців
Солом’янського району і зіткнувся з першою проблемою.
Мені усно відразу сказали: «Перепрошуємо,
але у вас немає реєстрації і ми нічого не можемо зробити».
Сказали, навіть немає сенсу писати заяву.
Але Дмитро не поступився. Майже два місяці вивчав закони,
стояв у чергах, подавав заяви і цілі стоси документів,
щоб підтвердити фактичне місце проживання в орендованій квартирі.
Але ані довідка переселенця, ані витяг з реєстру підприємців
чи декларація з поліклініки чиновників не переконали.
Дмитро навіть хотів стати на облік як безхатько,
би отримати таку бажану виборчу адресу.
Та наостанок - ще раз подав заяву з проханням визнати
свою фактичну – «переселенську» – адресу виборчою.
До неї долучив два судових рішення у схожих випадках.
Наступного дня, коли я прийшов за відмовою, щоб відразу подати позов до суду,
начальниця відділу сказала мені: «Вітаю вас.
розглянувши всі наведені факти, ми прийняли рішення,
що ваша заява має бути схвалена.
Ви зможете голосувати на цих виборах – вже у першому турі».
Випадок Дмитра – рідкість, каже Наталя Новікова,
менеджерка громадської організації «Група впливу».
Зазвичай виборці без зареєстрованого місця проживання мають лише три варіанти:
стати на облік як бездомні, купити фіктивну реєстрацію
або звернутися до суду.
Але позов не гарантує успіху – все залежить від рішення конкретного судді.
Проблему потрібно вирішувати системно, наголошує експертка.
А саме – відв’язати виборчу адресу від штампу у паспорті.
В Україні з її мільйонами переселенців і трудових мігрантів
ця проблема - давно актуальна.
Політики бояться внутрішньо переміщених осіб,
тому що вони не знають їх електоральних настроїв.
Вони думають, що, можливо, в цій категорії будуть
проросійські політичні погляди і тому вони не знають,
як реагувати на все це.
Але з іншого боку, ми розуміємо, що це просто небажання
ефективно працювати з виборцями.
Тим часом, переселенка з Донецька Неллі Селютіна
уже третю годину чекає у відділі ведення Держреєстру виборців.
Попереду – щонайменше стільки ж.
Але відмовлятися від свого конституційного права
вона не збирається – черги її не лякають.
Я вважаю, що мій голос дорого коштує.  Адже я знаю, як це -
коли ти не маєш права голосу, коли вибори проходять без тебе,
і ти не можеш проголосувати.
Я ціную це право і буду стояти стільки, скільки треба.
На відміну від Неллі Селютіної, витрачати час і нерви,
щоб тимчасово змінити місце голосування
і взяти участь у виборах, готова лише невелика частина виборців.
До першого туру це зробили тільки 300.000 громадян.
При цьому, за оцінками експертів, в Україні
декілька мільйонів виборців живуть не «за пропискою».
Скільки з них захочуть та встигнуть пройти всю процедуру знову,
до 15-го квітня – велике питання.
Адже часу на це у них цього разу буде обмаль –
лише тиждень, а не два місяці, як перед першим туром.